in north america many women are becoming
involved in affairs
the basic requirement being that there's
no feelings involved
if feelings become involved either way
then
it's over they seem to want unrelated
sexuality
how do you see this
i think it has two roots one
the deeper root is that the
many north american women are very
unhappy
basically because of the whole way of
the social life in north america it is
not enough rooted
people move too much about women have
very little chance to to establish roots
to the earth to a garden to a house
to a community to a surrounding where
they can stay
it is this constant moving which
rather pleases men but is very
unfortunate for women
and that damages the women's
instinctuality and then they want
to replace it by sex because that is
then so to speak
the last possibility to have something
to do with their own body
or to confirm their own physical
existence
but it's a desperate move which is a
surrogate for
something quite different a surrogate
for having no feminine
life no feminine rhythm of life
the whole rhythm of the north american
life is too hectic for a woman it's not
it damages women more than men it's not
good for men either but it damages women
even more
and then there is this whole world of
advertising and this whole
social idea of success and
girls having to date boys and inquiring
in
are you dating a boy already and so on
and it is all so the whole relationship
between the sexes becomes an affair of
success of social achievement instead of
feeling
and if a woman has not a strong
relationship to her own
instinctual feminine nature then she
falls for that kind of nonsense
women can run sex with
with the head so to speak completely
cool without feeling
as a as a means to confirm their
self-esteem
i must have a man i must have an affair
in order to
be prove myself to be normal and to
and because one does should have that
because it is a success
to have a man in one's pocket but it has
nothing to do with
the instinctual real feelings of a woman
she overruns those with a
theoretical idea of having to have a man
and having to have sex
and then the whole thing is a cold power
game
which leads to nothing
and then she runs a success life with
putty trying to conquer men and putting
them in her pocket
and boasting to her girlfriends about it
and it has nothing to do anymore with
her real feminine feelings